PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Welcome
to "Deconstructing Chatbots."
I'm Priyanka Vergadia,
and in this episode,
we will look at how to
help our ML algorithms
have better
conversations with users.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
For us humans,
conversation is natural.
It's a part of
our everyday life.
We fundamentally understand it
and all the nuances around it
because honestly, it's
part of who we are.
This is why trying to teach a
machine to have a conversation
is so difficult. It's all
about conversation experience.
OK, Google, what's the
weather like tomorrow?
GOOGLE: In Mountain
View tomorrow,
there will be scattered
showers with a high of 59
and low of 46.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: How
you interact with machines
right now seems pretty simple.
You just ask something,
and the machine responds.
But it turns out that this
is a really hard thing
to get right for a machine
since people ask for information
in various different ways.
For example, to do
something as simple
as get the weather
you could say,
what's the forecast
like today, or what's
the weather right now,
or what's the temperature
like in San Francisco tomorrow?
Now, if you were to
code this traditionally,
you'll most likely need a
whole matrix of conditionals
to figure out all the edge cases
for all the ways your users can
ask for this single information.
But as you can imagine, that's
not really maintainable.
This is where NLU or Natural
Language Understanding,
comes in.
NLU is a technology that
helps translate human language
into computer language
and vice versa.
It's very similar to
Natural Language Processing,
but it goes a step further
to understand conversations
that it hasn't been
trained to understand,
like errors, spelling
mistakes, accents, sentiments,
which makes NLU a
great fit for chatbots.
And what's really
nice is that NLU
works with both voice and text.
Now, NLU is very similar
to Machine Learning,
but it's not the same thing.
Rather, ML helps drive NLU by--
actually, we'll talk about
this in a later episode.
Stay tuned for that.
Now, a conversational experience
may not be on top of your list
when you're thinking
about customer support,
but it's actually
a critical element
to meet customer expectations
in a personalized manner.
And Google's Dialogflow
makes this possible.
Dialogflow lets you build
conversational interfaces
on top of your
products and services
providing a powerful Natural
Language Understanding
engine to process
and understand what
your users are looking for.
Which means when
you use Dialogflow,
you get all the value of
NLU engine for your chatbots
without having to lift a finger.
Sadly, we are out of time for
this episode, but that's OK.
We covered a lot of topics--
conversational experiences,
why they are important,
Natural Language Understanding,
and how Dialogflow lets you get
up and running really quickly.
Next, we are going to
learn some critical terms
in the chatbot world
which will prepare
us to go hands-on and
build an actual chatbot.
If that sounds exciting
to you, join me
in the next episode of
"Deconstructing Chatbots."
[MUSIC PLAYING]